I mean at the time I thought it was just
this Divine calling but now I think it
was just because I watched so much TV
you know yeah I grew up watching a lot
of TV and I think that it just sort of
like
um permeated my my being and I wanted to
be a Storyteller you know I wanted to be
a part of telling stories
and you know I my mom was not supportive
of me doing anything like as a young
person like I was part of these these
you know dance trips and singing groups
but she said when you're old enough to
do it on your own then you know take
yourself to an audition but which is
such good advice and I I highly
recommend that to people with kids
um it's better to wait
um
and um and then I just um yeah I started
modeling I guess when I graduated high
school
I wasn't sure like how to be an actor I
didn't know what you do
um I never knew well I did know someone
who was an actor because at my school
Michael J fox went to my school and
she's crazy did you know yeah you went
to my elementary school well he was
older than me but I knew of him
and um of course there are so many
Canadian Actors now but at the time
um you also didn't know if people were
Canadian right because we didn't have
Wikipedia or you didn't you know you
didn't know someone's bio or whatever
so I it just seemed kind of like an un
like I don't know how do you do that
um but my dream was pretty um the the
fire in me was pretty strong
did you say that yeah go continue yeah I
always have questions that I'm thinking
of a go yeah yeah and then I moved to um
I moved to Toronto to model and I was
modeling there and then I moved to then
went to Japan and did there and then I
moved to Europe
um
and I um was in Spain and modeling and
stuff like that and then I had an
audition when I was in Spain for a TV
show like an American TV show like a CBS
crime time after prime time kind of and
I got like this little part
that was a regular role like in Spain
like what's the likelihood that would
happen and I was terrible in it and
um and then they the next season was in
LA and so I drove to LA and you know I
had no money no car no green card no
I got my side card from that show and I
got a work visa from that show but I
mean I I mean I don't even know how I
did it I mean how did we even book
airline tickets back then I have no idea
but without a credit card or whatever
like was I going there with cash and
like handing the cash I mean I have no
clue
um but I do know we were calling collect
when we called home um
and then I came to LA and and um and I
was in LA and someone I turned I was
just turning 25 and um
and I just started working
a little bit just enough and
then I
got the Matrix you know and I mean you
did a lot of other stuff before that
yeah yeah I mean I did TV I did you know
I think I was just talking to a friend
about this I did models Inc when I was
20.
a six or something
um which was a Aaron Spelling show yeah
and at the time you know like all those
air inspiring shows were so big and I
think that probably that show was the
biggest learning curve and what set the
tone for my whole career because the
show was supposed to be huge
um we did publicity before we we got
into the the publicity
um wheel before the show even shot a day
of the show
and I always
thought that was odd
and I never got caught in it like
believing it
that's good and and it you know it
wasn't a successful show we did one
season
and
I understood
pretty early on that
our business is very unpredictable and I
use this analogy a lot
um I always looked at our business like
a big fat alcoholic
that
um Charming
great fun
but don't rely on it
and so I always had that attitude and
not in a negative way
but in a very kind of like you know I
never really thought about how a show
was gonna do or a movie was going to do
or I you know if it did really well like
I enjoyed it but I didn't buy into any
of it so I know how quickly I just like
it's this right it's it's boy are you
lucky are you you're lucky that you had
sort of that
subconscious I don't know Insight or
whatever yeah really grateful it really
served me really really well